the stars of homes and watson holmes and
watson themselves in christmas day
theaters near you uh will ferrell and
john c raleigh good to see you gentlemen
right here very much
thank you very much good to see you too
yeah right back at you
great to see you everyone not just you
rich i always say good to see you
because it's always
true no matter who it is it's good to
see you as in i'm glad i still have
eyesight i'm
able to see live yeah yeah well because
many people probably
come up to you john and will as well to
say you know we've met before and you
don't remember them do you go
just ahead and say good to see you again
just to cover your base i never say it
again because then you're get you're
tipping your hand
just say good to see you good to see you
in my tracks on occasion with uh
how you been that's another good generic
where you've been because if we haven't
met before
it doesn't matter you're still curious
i'm still i'm engaged
here's another one i have a friend who
when he sees someone coming towards him
like in a room that he's supposed to
know
you can tell i'm supposed to know this
person but i don't he goes
there he is there he is
it makes the person feel great you
haven't revealed that you don't know
their name you can get right into the
conversation sneaky good right there
sneaky i'll do a lot of there's my guy
that's a good one i don't know but how
you been is a good one
how you been i've been great see or hey
since i last saw you then i tip you uh
that we have
seen each other help us out a little bit
you know when i last saw you
it was at your kid's soccer game
remember actually that is in fact the
the best is that's the last time i saw
you yes
uh hey rich how are you man
i'm good yeah bob jensen
oh we worked together
how you been do you do you remember um
i was way in the background it was a
crowd scene
it was 2 000 extras
yeah yeah and then i can't help and i go
that doesn't count
no yeah so i was on an airplane last
night coming home from new york and this
flight attendant gave me a real hard
time
i have to say well she walks by and i've
been doing this flight back and forth a
million times so i guess maybe i've seen
some of these people
oh no repeatedly or whatever and i guess
i saw her a couple flights ago or
something she walked by and she's like
hey how you doing she waved to me she's
walking she didn't stop she just kept
walking hey how you doing
and i had headphones on i went hey like
that like hey
i could i couldn't i didn't even quite
hear what she said right
and then i'm getting up at the end of
the flight getting packing my stuff
and she sort of throws over a few people
while everyone's waiting to get out of
the plane like
yeah i guess you you're too big to say
hi oh
i was like what you didn't you know i
said hi to you you just
just ignored me i was like no i didn't i
waved to you
i was like wow this is the opposite of
customer service i'm getting i'm getting
i'm getting upgraded by the flight
attendant even though i did try
i felt so bad on my way out i said to
the other flight attendants
hey will you tell your colleague there
that i really i did try to say hi
back and i did not expect to be called
out on it
man customer abradement anyway great
story
no good way to start off this interview
yeah it's a great one john sitting next
to a guy dressed as a referee
you are now yeah let me so you are
dressed head to toe
with shorts and everything and high you
know high knee socks with my
ayso regional patch i don't know if you
want to get a tight shot of that yep
yep yep there it is and you are cause
you are legitimately
an american youth soccer
organizationally regional
national this doesn't cut any ice you
wouldn't let me on the field
park in beverly hills indeed and i was
dressed like this you were
in fact dressed like that i just hear
this voice go oh my god
and you look at those legs your daughter
had just played i believe he had just
lit it up excuse me i don't mean to be
if uh you know four or five goals
she loses he crushed it yeah she crushed
it and i was about to ref the next
couple games
exactly how are you as a ref though will
i mean uh
are you i mean how do you play it well i
am strictly what's called an ar
assistant referee so i'm the guy who
runs on the sideline with the flag
i thought arm and ass ref that's what
that's cause that i could that's what
it's turning into now i can see once you
get some power behind it you really tend
to
go crazy it depends on on how you work
the flag
if you point with the flag then you're
in that form of the ar
okay see if you point and then go up but
see i have no power i don't i don't have
the red cards or the yellow cards
and throw ins and things like that
because you could send some real
messages to your sons that's my sake
you know just random fouls this is about
the stuff at home
not on the field this is about what you
send me a breakfast smart ass
red red card out whatever that might
even know i don't even know what yeah
you you nailed it in fact red card
you're out yeah you're out
actually out you missed the next game
really can can you yellow card a 10 year
old
in a ysl oh yes
oh yes i'm not afraid no no you got a
quick trigger finger
yeah maybe that's why you're not
national will i don't mean to point it
out
maybe that's why you know you're still
in the region
that's my second career to become a
national
ayso referee but yeah you could be world
cup
you know what you could get the thing i
love about the referees in the world cup
is that uh that spray that they put down
on the shaving cream did you break
you should have i wish i had that i
if i made a if i could referee in a fifa
game
i wouldn't be the perfect it would just
be a can of barbasol yeah
a real thick ample line
and build about like a about six inches
off the ground yeah
spend a lot of time right there you know
what i would genuinely love for you as a
second career if you ever decided you
wanted a second career
is to see you follow through in that
promise to usc
right and finally be a broadcaster be
someone who's calling color right
rich maybe you could give me a break i
mean that would that would boost ratings
for whatever sport you were talking
about if i took over the rich eisen show
yeah you did yeah i mean you want to
switch seats well you don't have to do
that
which sport would you want to do if you
could choose which sport
uh what you'd want to call a game will
you i don't you could bring a lot of
good focus to curling
you know a sport that needs it i wasn't
prepared for this line of questioning
you know what though i did do we did do
ron burgundy did help announce the
national curling finals in ottawa canada
about five years ago how'd that go
it was amazing absolutely amazing
because
people called in and said people who had
no idea that who the character was
said they that i had ruined the
national calling finals because this guy
doesn't know the game
they gave me the telestrator at one
point and
the the the guys were the curling
announcers who were like the
you know vin scully's of curling they
played it straight they loved it because
they don't get to mess around
and they're like ron what do you think
of this play what do you think the
approach is and i would just like well i
think he's trying to put it over here
and
they had all these ads for tim horton's
coffee which is a big coffee chain
for our canadian listeners and i just
kept saying
all this signage i'm like who the hell
is tim horton
who does he think he is get him out of
here
and so you can just hear these guys in
the curling locker room afterwards
i've worked my whole life to get here
and when that guy
comes out here and makes an ass off
forget it i fly all the way to ottawa
the paris of canada
and you run for this you run directly
into the
the cadre of curling purists that you
never knew existed
but i literally was doing some press the
next day and one of the jurors was like
that was fantastic but my mother called
and said there's a guy with a mustache
who's horrible he doesn't know what he's
talking about he's ruining he ruined the
event for me
right uh well what about uh hosting the
oscars
as ron burgundy would that fly do you
think or
maybe john you know honestly i think
that might be the move for somebody i
don't know if it's for will
but a fictional character is an
unimpeachable
character right how about that's true
otherwise whoever it is
like i'm gonna find something that you
did wrong or something that's
you know how about reid rothschild i
mean he was read he was
he was in film of some sort
reid would prove more fairly than uh
well he was fair more poorly rather than
see is read still out in van nuys
probably yeah he's in the magic circuit
he's he's doing magic he's doing this
porn magic act it's
just never quite caught on living out in
chatsworth yeah it's kind of a dedicated
fan
group of about 10 people or so that come
but yeah you could still travel
you would get in so much trouble are you
kidding it would be
yeah it would be a mess it would make
you know this latest debacle look
tame just get his tapes back finally
maybe it finally gets a ticks back
yeah what do you know that's an mp
not a yp that is one of my favorite
lines
that i get to use actually on this show
when fans call in and people why are
they complaining about refereeing
whatever i'm like that's that's that's
and that's a that's a why p not i don't
know who played that part is robert
downey senior
robert downey jr's father is that right
yeah and he
improvised that line mpyp come on yeah
no he just came up with it on the spot
how about that all right so let's talk
holmes and watson here yeah
by all means that's in theaters near you
right on uh
on christmas day okay absolutely are you
is this a watson
uh outfit yeah that's an inspired outfit
i mean i can tell you
john when we were in london yeah there
was not a day that
went by where john didn't break out
brand new tweed left he loves
he loves a good tweed suit he wears it
well yeah in
england it's like it's it's sort of like
the cargo shorts of
of england what for is l.a it's cargo
shorts and tank tops
yeah it's a three-piece sweet suit in
england and the reason is because
it breathes it can get wet and you don't
get cold like it's a very functional
garment for england right now i'm
sweating down the back of my ass
we're all the way down like it's pooling
between my butt cheeks
the wicking nature of the tweed isn't it
i'm sucking it off your body at the same
time swoosh
[Music]
moving around in the mixture of tweed
and pleather which is i've never had
that a possibility meanwhile
so you're talking about sweating down
the back your ass crack this poly
shirt's working good too
you both are rethinking your your garb
choices i'm not really thinking the high
socks yeah that i'm good with
the shorts are pretty short too i mean
they're stocked in length right there
look at that ample thigh that's a ham
hockey right there look at that
that's ready for heart that's ready for
market so you might want to smoke that
for a couple days
you guys want to slice put some hickory
around it
so uh holmes and watson uh was there
ever any consideration of being
playing the other or are you just you
were always that's absurd
i'm clearly john watson yes
i never even really i can't someone's
asked us that before and it's like
what are you nuts obviously will is
sherlock holmes
obviously he's got the pipe collection
and everything already
i've got the bird-like features yes you
do nimble
i've got the brain right uh no john
played
plays a wonderful put upon watson
the you know always would would run
through a brick wall
for his beloved sherlock holmes right
and in a call back to step brothers
uh i i do play a learned doctor in this
one
i lived in a house of learned doctors
for step brothers but i play about
he plays a real doctor so it's a natural
but
yeah from point a to b yeah but uh but i
yeah i i i
i can i put poor watson has to eat
various
he's poisoned at times i throw him at j
throw him in jail
you know he's there's bees there's
experiments i do experiments on him in
real time yeah in order to solve
my hypothesis yeah on so many different
things and the english accents uh how
how hard did you work on the english
because you kept it throughout it
throughout yeah uh which is fairly
intimidating when you're on a crew of
entirely
british people who every time you
mispronounce one word they're like
um and they're not even acting popular
we tried as hard as we really did
very accurate english accents and that's
why it's funny
because we're not that great at it
either of us
uh but the whole movie kind of makes fun
of english people
yeah i mean there's a lot of social
mores and
i mean brexit right come on what's up
with that
that's a good idea very timely we
thought we had problems yeah
guess what very very interesting you got
brexit okay
uh that's in theaters you know you will
ferrell and uh john c reilly on
on christmas day uh so you i honestly
when i
i was told that you might be showing up
in some sort of garb here
right uh i thought you would wear an la
fc
uh outfit as an owner of an actual
you're an actual i mean actual owner of
a sports franchise
how are you as an owner is there a
steinbrennerian streak are you
what are you as an owner i am exacting
with your coach or what
what i am i am at of the ownership group
of the adult table at the ownership
group i'm at the kids table
yes i'm at the fold out the cardboard
table oh
uh and uh yeah i'm not allowed in the
big meetings
what do you mean come on now you know
you should have like some mandatory
player parties at your house like
daytime parties
i uh oh no i'm saying i was making a
crack about soccer not being that
popular in america
you know 72 000 people for the mls final
game this year
so it's uh it's absolutely shut your
mouth john riley
it's about what is baseball
i think that's a good thing i mean less
concussions am i right
right wait they're in soccer there's
fewer less than baseball
well no i'm probably more i've just seen
these nfl ads where they're like
it's a lot safer than it looks folks
don't worry
really you're looks like some very
strong guys bashing into each other as
hard as you can
i think those are the anti-smoking ray
liotta commercials that are all over oh
yeah
i think i'm loving that chance right i
mean it's everywhere right now
it's kind of crazy have you seen someone
did a mash-up of
ray leotta's performances or scenes from
good fellas
and champions yeah and put it over the
chances it's going to be amazing it's
pretty stunning i have to say
it was really really funny i mean all
due respect rayleigh
ray and mr scripture he's a jail afc fan
is he really no i don't know he's in the
non-smoking section a lot of the players
are on champions
they take chances by the way we we here
on this show always say with all due
respect
in advance of saying something
completely disrespectful
you know what i mean i didn't make the
video so i'm not i'm just mentioning it
no i'm sorry but
about to laugh without all due respect
to ray leota you know what i mean like
that's all that's all i'm saying yeah
you know what i mean so uh
i'm glad that he stopped smoking because
there's no future in smoking
i agree with no future in it i'm glad
this is i'm glad you you feel the same
way
you know uh so before i let you guys go
um
is there any possibility that we see a
step brothers
sequel from the two of you guys here we
go this is gonna be the headline of
whatever this
interview is about space no well if
there is then we'll make sure we mention
that that
that holmes and watson there's in
theaters near you on the 25th
december i mean we haven't never talked
about this uh face-to-face in public no
we haven't so let's
let's break some ground here uh are we
gonna do step brothers too i don't think
so
yeah i don't think it's gonna happen
either that's what i thought
yeah but now we can both say
definitively it doesn't look like it's
gonna happen folks so i'm sorry but
we'll try to make some other good movies
for you yeah like this christmas present
that we're giving you on christmas day
okay hope you like it okay yeah
all right fair enough well you know i
know you're a little
yeah well we we we're trying we're
trying to branch out
i hate that our movie that people love
so much has become a source of
disappointment when we talk about it
like we said there won't be another one
oh really i love that one
all right well i'm sorry i bummed you
out like we didn't make it in the first
place
like you did we put it out all right
well
you know i had to put up the photoshop
maybe we'll put up the photoshop anyway
[Music]
you know there's me there is the third
you make sense in that world somehow
rich
you could be like a friend of dr dobax
did you get in these would they put your
head on us now
we go yeah we just kind of i guess
proper puffy top
yeah you know that just flipped the john
c reilly one that's all
got it that's the magic technology
that's the magic that's the magic it's
the magic
dr dovak's anesthesiologist that works
with him at the
hospital see we're workshopping now
we're spitballing yeah
okay thanks for coming in guys thank you
has been just an absolute
blast and i can't wait to see this film
with everybody and all my friends please
do i hope so
yeah okay we're not you are we raising
the flag on
on this interview at all will it's just
awesome you know what i it kills me
i was gonna bring my flag that i have to
bring because i get mad at you if you
don't
right and it would have been just such a
great button
on what we've done today but it's it's
it's at home it's at home i don't know
what to do you know what you
like i said just to bring it all full
circle you want to go national and you
just need to be
you do have my whistle you do oh
it's like neon is that good for audio
how's that for the radio honestly the
level's good okay
john c raleigh holmes and watson in
theaters on christmas day uh
come back any time guys really enjoy uh
next time i'm on my way to the airport
i'm getting off early do that and i'm
coming here richard stop yeah i'm right
here
i'll drop by and and you'll say hello to
every flight attendant possible just
next time next time i'm dropping off my
fedex package because i don't dress the
delivery guys i take it right to
distribution
take it right here i place it on the
plane
for overnight you cover all bases
covering all bases all right again check
out holmes and watson uh will ferrell
and john c
reilly here on the rich eisen show the
rich eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience